[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir mes petits amis au trot
mais oui mon gros nounours descend vite
leur montrer ton beau livre et moi je
leur raconte la suite des aventures de
notre petite amie cornichons bon job
[Musique]
propos
les parents de cornichons n'ont pas
encore retrouvé leur fils et continue à
le chercher partout mais celui-ci ne
s'ennuie pas tu es prêt nounours je suis
preuve de trop en vous vous pouvez
raconteuse cornichons habite à présent
chez son ami bûcheron dans la grande
forêt il en a appris des choses qu'il a
appris à siffler comme le merle
oui et à roucouler comme les pigeons
comme sien oui et à chanter comme le
coucou qui fait coucou chaque matin
notre petite amie se lève très tôt il va
se laver au bord de la rivière isle et
courage et si tu aimes fouet puis il
s'en va travailler avec son ami
le gros bûcheron couple de grands arbres
avec sa grosse hache et cornichons
l'aide de son mieux mais ce qu'il
préfère c'est de grimper dans les arbres
et de se cacher dans les feuillages
cornichons ou le cul du chevron des
chevrons regarde ce que j'ai trouvé
il a découvert tout en haut d'un arbre
honey honey dans lequel se trouve un
petit bout qui on voit mal un bond époux
corniche on le prend délicatement et il
descend vite le montrer à son ami ce tu
le dis le bûcheron je trouve les
cornichons lui aussi trouve le petit
bout très jolie avec ses grands yeux
ronds bûcheron si nous le gardions avec
nous d'accord répond son ami pour lui
faire plaisir
il ramène le petit bout dans leur cabane
en bois tu t'appelles julietta dudit
cornichons
[Musique]
nos deux amis se couche après avoir
manger leur soupe et notre petit
corniche on s'endort en pensant à sa
maman son papa et à son ami dada tandis
que juliette a fait sur lui et tire ses
grandes à elle dans les rayons de la
lune
il en a de la veine c'est l'ambition il
en fait des loups
oui mais il n'a pas encore retrouvé sa
famille ne t'en veux pas et va leur
trouver cette annonce bien sûr les
enfants
l'histoire est finie on va changer du
dimanche ce qu'ils sont et non
[Musique]
nathalie bany bonne nuit les petits
là j'étais mieux atone
km bonne nuit petit nicolas bonne nuit
petit pape rhône elle
28 tous les enfants allez vite vous
coucher auparavant n'oubliez pas de
faire votre toilette et de pian vous
l'affublent dont il fait de beaux rêves
à demain bono
[Musique]
oh
en